we start to see the outlines of the way
a path of karma yoga might work
and how we might bring it into our own
lives
we see the possibility that we can turn
whatever it is we do every day into a
path to god
krishna has given arjuna given us
two instructions so far about how to go
about doing that
first he said we listen to hear what our
dharma is
and we try to become harmonious with
that in our actions
next we perform each act as purely as we
can
without thinking about any rewards but
there is one more key instruction in
this practice of karma yoga
and it's the one that flips the game out
to another level
not only do you do your dharma and act
without regard to its fruits
in addition to all that you act without
thinking of yourself as being the actor
the action is happening through you
but you aren't doing it you have stepped
out of the way
that puts you in a whole new perspective
in relation to your actions
krishna tells arjuna all actions take
place in time
by the interweaving of the forces of
nature the gunas
but the man lost in selfish delusion
thinks that he himself is the actor
krishna is saying look you're not doing
anything
it's a delusion to imagine you are
you're not the actor
what's happening is just the sum total
of millions of laws playing themselves
out through you once you see that
really see that you're home free because
your sense of i
acting in the world is stripped away
so the karma yogi is the person who uses
his or her life to come to god
by listening for the dharmic act acting
without attachment to the outcome
all the while knowing she or he's not
the actor anyway
that's the whole formula for turning our
lives around
and making them our spiritual practice
the warrior in the carlos castaneda
books gives us another model of the
perfect karma yogi
all the things don juan says about the
warrior
refer to the karma yogi as well
a warrior is a hunter he calculates
everything
that's control but once his calculations
are over
he acts he lets go and he survives in
the best of all possible fashions
the mood of a warrior calls for control
over himself
and at the same time it calls for
abandoning himself
we can hear in that a description of
some of the qualities that come into our
actions when we're not attached to the
outcome and not busy being the actors
there's a sense of equanimity for
example
castaneda talks about it as a sense of
control
yet self-surrender there's great
spontaneity
and at the same time a quality of loving
attention
because each act is our offering
our flower at god's feet
if we're acting from that place it shows
up in each thing we do
even simple things like making a cup of
tea
garchief used to say if you can serve a
cup of tea
properly you can do anything that is if
you are able to perform
any act in a true karma yogic fashion
it's because you're acting from a place
where you're free of attachments
and not busy being the actor and being
in that place will
shape every act you do
the book of dao says by letting it go
it all gets done the world is won
by those who let it go but when you try
and try
the world is then beyond the winning
if you're going to make a cup of tea
right you can't be busy trying to make
the cup of tea right
because while you're busy trying you're
not present with making the tea
you can't be doing both
the right way to make a cup of tea is to
start by bringing together
everything you need to make the tea
including the knowledge of how to do it
and then you make the tea while you're
making the tea
you're just making the tea nothing else
you're not worrying about how the tea
will turn out and you're not wondering
whether you're good enough to make the
tea correctly
and you're not thinking about whether
you should serve it with honey
you're just right there making the tea
now you're rinsing the kettle now you're
filling it
now you're putting it on the stove being
present with every step
and acting out of the total harmony of
each moment
the more purely we flow into our karmic
circumstances
the more our acts are just happening
there's no struggle
there's no anxiety because we don't care
how the act turns out
there's no self-consciousness because
there's no actor involved
he who sees the inaction that is in
action
and the action that is in inaction is
wise indeed
even when he is engaged in action he
remains poised in the tranquility
of the ottoman but we can't fake it
that's just more attachment we can't
pretend we're right there making the tea
when we're really not when really we're
lost in the thought of how well we're
making the tea
we have to start from where we're at
right in this moment
so here we are we're still stuck with
all our desires
most of the things we're doing we're
doing because we want something out of
it
and we can't make believe where other
than what we are
what do we do how do we work with our
actions as yoga
when we know how caught we still are
and most important of all how do we know
for sure
what it is we're supposed to do
the answer is we don't the truth of it
is
until you are no longer attached to your
ego in any way
every act you do will have your ego
present in it
there's not a chance it won't right up
to the end
there are going to be mixed motives
subtle ways in which you'll do it to
yourself
again and again that's what's so funny
about this battle
i've said before that the span of
progress on the spiritual path
is about one body length we take a step
and we fall flat on our faces because it
was another impure trip
so we pull ourselves up and we take the
next step
and we fall on our faces again that
seems to be about the rate at which we
go
so when you're listening to hear your
dharma there is very little likelihood
that you're going to hear the
pure message you're just going to hear
another message but you keep tuning and
tuning
through study through meditation through
falling on your face
and slowly slowly as your methods start
to work
your attachment to the whole business
starts to get less and less
after all the ego can only trap you as
long as you think you are
it when it's just out there doing its
thing
when it's just egoing like eyes seeing
or ears hearing it becomes merely a
functional
entity nothing more interesting than
that
in the meantime you do the best you can
you look at the next step you're about
to take and you ask yourself
what seems to be the right next thing to
do
then you become quiet and you listen
inside for an answer
you get as quiet as you can and you
listen as clearly as you can
but you recognize that in spite of that
it's probably not going to be a pure
message from beyond the beyond
very likely it'll still have plenty of
your desire systems mixed in with it
once you've decided as best you can you
act
keeping in mind that you are not the
actor while you're acting
you don't second guess yourself you
don't waste your time wondering whether
you made the right decision
you're done deciding now you're acting
be present with your actions after
you've finished if you want to
you can sit back and reflect and say was
that the right choice
that's different but while you're doing
it do it fully
when you're making tea make tea when
you're brushing your teeth
brush your teeth when you're making love
make love big axe small acts
whatever it is be fully there with it
stop ruining things for yourself with
that self-conscious
judgmental holding back what we're
letting go of
in that process is the old self-critical
inner voice
the old super ego that's so afraid of
blowing it
afraid of making a mistake afraid of
looking like a fool
that is not the same you'll notice as
the impersonal
inner witness the practice of noting
what we're experiencing
that's the thing we're trying to
cultivate witnessing
has a totally different quality to it
it's
observing not judging the judging
super ego is incompatible with acting in
the moment
the impersonal witness is the essence of
acting in the moment
so karma yoga turns out to be a
technique for extracting ourselves from
the turmoil of life
not by an action but by shifting
perspectives on our actions
no longer are our actions a means to
fulfill our desires
now there are opportunities for
spiritual practice
for practice and being unattached to the
outcome
and for practice and getting rid of the
idea that we're doing anything
we do what we do all the time
recognizing that it's just the wheel of
karma
the dance of god's play the laws
lawfully unfolding through us
we see that it was only our incredible
egocentricity that made us think we were
doing it
and as we begin to see ourselves that
way
not as the actors but as the vehicles
through which the laws of nature are
unfolding
we are approaching something which is
much more interesting
and much more profound than whatever it
was we might have thought the game was
about
krishna points to it when he says i have
no work to do
in all the worlds arjuna for these are
mine
i have nothing to obtain because i have
it all
and yet i work
and yet i work isn't that interesting
he's saying look i don't have any karma
there's nothing i have to do but i act
anyway
coming from that space of no ego and no
attachment
there clearly has to be a whole
different motive for acting
you see we've really been talking about
starting with our desires
starting with our attachments and using
them as a way of coming to union
it's out of our desire to come to the
one
out of our desire to be liberated out of
our desire to surrender
that we listen to hear our dharma and
that we do it
we do our dharma to fulfill a desire
within the desire system
there's an attachment in there the
attachment to getting liberated
and that's what motivates us to work but
if all that is true
then once we get liberated and have no
attachments
why would we work krishna is letting us
in on a whole new basis for action here
imagine a person who has absolutely no
personal desire to do
anything not even to get enlightened
she's got it she is it
she's not trying to develop herself
she's already there
she has no more moral motives she's
beyond
good and evil so what is she doing
doing anything ananda mahima
was a beautiful saint in india someone
who was living in that place
someone whose actions were totally free
yet she set up hospitals dispensaries
schools
what was she doing with all those
ashrams and all that service
was she doing karma yoga outwardly
her actions might have seemed like that
but the spirit of it
the motive from which she was acting was
completely different
the motive was different in that there
was no motive
there was no intention behind her
actions
she was just being the expression of
dharma
being compassion with beings like that
beings like or my guru
it's that spirit behind their actions
which is the transmission
the true guru is someone whose very life
is a statement of how it all
is when you're done with it all and any
forms or acts that the guru uses
are merely the vehicles for that
transmission
such a being is beyond the gunas beyond
the forces of nature
no longer attached at all to body mind
reason senses but using them still
in that place you're no longer doing
karma yoga
you're the expression of it
maher baba said to penetrate into the
essence of all being and significance
and to release the fragrance of that
entertainment for the guidance and
benefit of others
by expressing in the world forms of
truth
love purity and beauty this
is the soul game which has any intrinsic
and absolute worth
all other happenings incidents and
attainments can
in themselves have no lasting importance
yoga has been called a practice for
concentrating all our faculties on a
single point
in order to transcend the limitations of
ego
but karma yoga who would have suspected
that the road to god would lead us by
way of the household in the marketplace
the world becomes the means for
extricating ourselves from the strands
of worldly attachment
what an ingenious flip instead of
entangling us
suddenly our acts set us free
the gita says who in all his work sees
god
in truth he goes to god
when we first set out to do our work as
spiritual practice
we are still operating from inside the
world of attachments and desires
because the desire to get free is still
a desire
but as the upaya the method begins to
work
it leads us to a deeper understanding of
the reason
and wisdom that underlie the whole
system
we see who we are and what it is that's
going on
in a different light and along with that
understanding comes an increasing
impersonality toward our own lives
impersonality not less involvement
but less romanticizing of it all less
melodrama
less doer we go on living our lives
and we live them as perfectly as we can
but we live them
in an increasingly detached way
less and less are we acting out of our
motives or our desires
not even out of the high-minded ones
like enlightenment
we're just acting because it's our
dharma to act
that's essence karma yoga